it's finally here the greatest
technology to push us into the future
it's magical what these flimsy often
overpriced annoying pieces of plastic
are often referred to as dongles connect
our past to a future
whoa totally believable right and it's a
big year for these things because ports
app will close up the headphone port on
the iPhone 7 and in the worlds of
androids and laptops there's a global
shift underway to USB type-c if you've
bought a new phone or laptop in the last
year you're getting a dongle but
remember this not all dongles are the
ones you will want to take into the
future if you care more about your
laptop or Android phone than the iPhone
7 headphone adapter Palooza pause this
video and fast forward to a screen that
looks like this with the USB type-c port
okay yes
Apple was kind enough to include this $9
adapter in the iPhone 7 box so you can
plug your old regular headphones into
the phone but what happens when you want
to charge at the same time for that
Apple teamed up with Belkin on the $40
audio plus charge rock star adapter it
has two Lightning ports so you can
charge while listening to music with
Apple's new including earbuds but what
happens when you want to use your older
headphones double dongle that's what
happens yes you could plug in the
headphone adapter into the Lightning
port adapter or you could get this $25
option from f/stop labs which lets you
charge while listening to older
headphones unfortunately in my tests the
audio quality wasn't great so you've got
a new Android phone or laptop that no
longer has these but a new USB type-c
port it's actually a great court it's
faster and reversible so no more of this
if you have an Android phone these
little adapters that convert old
microUSB
into USBC chords are awesome anchor
cells - for $8.00 if you have a new
laptop with a type C port you're going
to need a USB C to regular USB adapter
Apple charges nineteen for one of these
anchor charges nine but i really suggest
a multi port super dongle like this $50
hyperdrive five in one hub Apple charges
$80 for a similar product all those
products have been certified by the USB
if' organization if you're buying a USB
type-c device look for these logos or
check the website to make sure they're
certified non-compliant products have
caused device damage or worse I guess it
is just a dumb piece of plastic